it is definitely not frightful on the
weather outside beautiful view here from
our camera on top of the caesars
entertainment headquarters around the
215 in the airport connector tunnel
every once in a while you get to see an
airplane going by across the runway but
we also want to concentrate on what's
going to be a blue sky day today
officially
we're back up to 58 degrees after 56 an
hour ago but what's happening in your
neighborhood it is a little bit chillier
though so as you're getting up and at
them you'll want to make sure that you
got a sweater or a light jacket
we'll have that bus stop forecast for
you in a few minutes for now aliente
you're at 50 the warm spots well we have
some 58s downtown the air force base and
sunrise mountain let's go to nevada and
beyond always cooler up in the northern
part of the silver state
cedar city i'm sorry you guys were in
the 40s a couple of minutes ago kingman
at 43
death valley at 62 so here over the next
couple of hours
we'll be back into the low 60s by eight
we'll shoot for the mid 70s at noon just
gorgeous
80 for you by three in the afternoon
trying for an afternoon high of 84.
mild not wild easy ride on the temp
roller coaster and a nice weekend ahead
in fact let's
jump ahead and talk about over the next
few days we're just going to see a few
clouds and breezes
now some potentially damaging weather
across the northern and central plains
all the way down to the deep south maybe
some flash flooding
from some severe thunderstorms but after
84 today we get you to 86
tomorrow maybe sliding back a couple of
degrees with some high clouds on friday
and got the golden knights at t-mobile
friday night saturday the warmest of the
next eight days with 88
sunday is the afternoon game out of
t-mobile and guy and i are going to that
game